often called one of the greatest feats
of human engineering the Panama Canal is
a 77 thermometer long man-made stretch
of water that was created to make
shipping and travel easier
before to get from one ocean to the
other ships had to sail all the way
around Cape Horn an extra 8,000 nautical
miles
so in 1881 some French engineers who had
just built the hugely successful Suez
Canal which connects the Indian Ocean to
the Mediterranean Sea decided they'd
have a crack of building one across
Panama now the tricky thing about
crossing landmasses with boats is that
boats are kind of stuck to the body of
water that they're floating on and water
always tries to flow down towards Sealab
now the Suez Canal engineers solve that
problem by simply digging a channel
through the land at sea level allowing
seawater to flow freely through it
unfortunately Panama's mountainous
terrain was quite different to Egypt and
required a ton more costly digging than
the French engineers ever anticipated
also their design would have run into
even more problems because as it turns
out the Pacific Ocean sea level is 20
centimeters higher than that on the
Atlantic
which would have created hell of
tricking currents going through the
canal and if that wasn't bad enough for
the French engineers tropical diseases
like the yellow fever spread through
their workforce because well they didn't
have the vaccines for them yet and in
the end they had to abandon the project
at an enormous cost
[Music]
however the potential payoff of having a
canal through Central America was just
too huge to the US resumed the project a
few decades later their design was a bit
different instead of cutting down to sea
level they figured it made more sense to
take the boat up and over the land
somehow to do this
they built exam across the checkers
River to create a huge man-made lake
that would cover a large part of the
land and make up most of the waterway
that the ships could travel across each
Lots has a huge gate at either end which
holds the lake water back after a ship
enters water is allowed in until the
levels of each side of the gate are
equal height which lifts the ship up in
the process then the gates can open and
the ship moves on to the next step the
largest of the gates are almost 8 meters
high and over 2 metres thick and it's
very important that they're strong
because if they fail well it would
create a catastrophic flood of water
downstream well normal sized boat this
is one full of Panamax pretty much the
largest boat that can fit through the
canal and well it's enormous so what has
happened is it was in the first spot the
water drains out of that one filled up
the other one until they were equal then
the gates opened and now the boat is
moving through and then it carries on
through the next gate and then it's back
out to the sea
since it opened just over a hundred
years ago the Panama Canal has become
one of the busiest waterways in the
world with over 13,000 ships passing
through it each year and in 2015 alone
over 340 million tons of goods are
through it which accounted for 6% of the
world trade and it certainly makes the
country of Panama very happy as it
brings in around 2 billion dollars a
year in revenue for their treasury so
you factor in all those stats it's no
wonder that Panama Canal is considered
one of the seven wonders of the modern
world
[Music]